is what I've been doing to no longer
poop water I've been having this much
kimchi I have like this much sauerkraut
four times a day and I've also added
some ginger root I'll take like three of
these as well
and I'm no longer shedding water okay
lots of questions here about not getting
water so kimchi and sauerkraut are
sources of probiotics like the
lactobacillus strains which having shown
to help with IBS when it comes to
diarrhea specifically one meta-analysis
found that the consumption of fermented
foods like kimchi like sauerkraut
significantly reduce the duration and
severity of diarrhea as for ginger we've
long used ginger for diarrhea dominant
IBS but a 2020 animal study found that
Ginger capsules reduced intestinal
hypersensitivity of ibsd by inhibiting
pro-inflammatory response and like
fermented foods Ginger's risk profile is
incredibly low so I think both of these
tips are really great so congrats
Jackson on the better poops